I see so many myths about which  ingredients are allowed in the U.S to  abandoned in the EU so I thought I'd  make a series starting with talc talc is  not banned in the EU it is listed in nx3  which is the list of ingredients with  restrictions but if you look at the  specific restriction it's just that if  your talc product is meant for children  under three you need to put a warning  saying to keep it away from their nose  and mouth there are no other  restrictions and in fact Health baby  powders are a lot easier to find in  Europe than the US these days most of  the dirty ingredients people say abandon  the EU aren't actually banned